get ready along like about along what
club
I'll be going over the top ten benefits
of Prayer
with the intention and hope but this
will motivate those who haven't yet
established a prayer those who might
have left the prayer or struggling with
the prayer as a part of their life
because it's very sad my little sister
that today we see so many Muslims not
establishing the prayer Salah in their
lives
despite its extreme importance that's
why I decided to make a short reminder
with the top ten benefits of prayer with
the bonus at the end now there's a lot
more but I'll keep it simple just go
over these top 10 let's start with
number 10 prayer is a means of
strengthening our relationship with God
Almighty Allah helping us to be grateful
and it's proven that grateful people
happy people being thankful for all his
blessings and to remind ourselves of his
greatness just as the body requires
physical needs such as food and water
the soul also requires spiritual needs
which are nourished by the acts of
worship that we do in Islam the most
important of which is prayer brothers
and sisters it could be that the body of
a person is healthy but is spiritually
dead this is substantiated when the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him said that the comparison of the
one who remembers God Almighty Allah and
the one who does not is like that of the
living and the dead Allah the Almighty
also says in the Quran o you who believe
respond to the call of Allah and his
messenger when he calls you - that gives
you life so Quran chapter 824 that which
gives the heart and soul life is prayer
otherwise you'll always have a deep void
inside yourself that's why so many
people turn to drugs alcohol and other
types of evil addiction moving along to
number 9 having a direct connection with
your Creator in Islam prayers a direct
connection with God
learn from prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him when he said that
the closest the person is to his Lord is
when he isn't prostration prayer
connects you with God you know that the
Arabic word for prayer salat actually is
derived from the Arabic word meaning
connection God's messenger said peace be
upon him when any of you stands to pray
he is communicating with his Lord so let
him pay attention to how he speaks to
him brothers and sisters don't sever
this relationship with your Creator
number eight you're establishing a
pillar of Islam prayer is the second
most important pillar and it's the most
regular compulsory action in our life
prayer is the one act that must be
fulfilled at least five times a day
regardless of the circumstance in fact
God Almighty Allah
they're not even exempt the Muslims from
praying during the times of battle a law
says guard strictly your prayers if you
fear an enemy pray on foot o or while
riding this is in the Quran chapter 2
238 think about that if that's the case
during war what about during peace
number seven success lies in prayer
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him said the first thing a person
will be accountable for on the day of
judgment will be their prayers if they
are good and sound that person will be
successful brothers and sisters what if
it's defective or imagine if it's not
even there your demon you didn't even
establish the salaat that connection
with your Lord big problems big problems
number six
it's your shield against evil the prayer
if done right shields one against evil
my brothers and sisters without seeking
God's help it is impossible to refrain
from evil God says in the Quran chapter
29 45 verily prayer restrains one from
shameful and unjust deeds think about it
how much more mindful and God conscious
of their actions the person going to be
standing in front of their Lord their
Creator five times a day number five
prayer enriches your soul prayers
satisfied that spiritual need that we
all have a yearning inside the depths of
us to wanting to be in contact and
connect it to our Creator and when that
need is fulfilled
it gives your soul peace contentment
especially with our busy and hectic
lifestyles Allah says in the Quran
chapter 13 verse 28 without a doubt and
the remembrance of Allah do hearts find
satisfaction peace contentment otherwise
the heart and soul will never be
satisfied and it will look for it in all
the wrong places
moving along to number 4 prayer done
right helps you to be more humble we
work with the prayer to get rid of the
pride arrogance and the big ego by
realizing Allah the Almighty's greatness
and you're dependent on him in the
prayer we put the highest part of the
human body and the source of
intelligence our heads onto the ground
and say how perfect is my Lord the most
high a law tells us in the Quran chapter
23 verse 1 - - successful indeed are the
believers who are humble in their
prayers of course this can only be
achieved when you understand what is
recited and you concentrate with
moving along only three more left number
three washes sins away did you know that
the prayer in Islam and washes your sins
away god almighty is the most loving and
merciful he didn't send any innocent
person to die for your sins he alone
forgives all sins when you repent
sincerely praying and asking him alone
everyone commits sins however Allah has
provided through prayer a way to wipe
out those things Allah says in the Quran
chapter 11 114 and performed prayer
surely the good deeds removed away the
evil deeds we also have another
beautiful example from the last and
final mission of problem Hamid peace and
blessings be upon him when he said to
his companions consider if one of you
had a river by his door front of the
house and which he bade in at five times
a day he asked with any filth remain on
you after that they said no Messenger of
Allah and the Prophet replied likewise
God wipes away the sins with the five
daily prayers
number two the prayer it will solve your
problems and unite stone remember that
whoever strengthens their relationship
with God God will strengthen the
relationship between themselves and the
creation Allah who is all-powerful will
rectify all your problems Allah the
Almighty says in the Quran chapter 2 153
seek help and patience in prayer prayer
it unites the Muslims those who have
submitted to God
congregational prayer cultivates
Brotherhood equality and humility
between Muslim worshippers standing in
rows
and as one body shoulder-to-shoulder
without any distinction of race
nationality color wealth or status this
act of unity and the prayer helps
demolish all barriers which stand
between people number one
the key to paradise is prayer prayer is
your key to Jenna this is a direct
hadith where the prophets all of Salaam
said mr. whole genitive to that the key
to Jenna
paradise is Salah this is in JAMA at
enmity an authentic hadith my sincere
advice brothers and sisters don't lose
this key it's your key to paradise
you lost it to get up right now go pray
2 rakaats two units of prayer lake toba
turn back repent and start fresh now
today don't wait for tomorrow because
tomorrow may never come and there are
only two places to go after your
departure from this world when you die
which is coming very soon and come today
tomorrow in a month or in a year or 60
years but for sure we'll all die and
it's either paradise or the Hellfire who
rather have paradise say I and get that
key hold on to the key don't lose the
key your prayer salat the direct
connection with your Creator now I
promised you a bonus we don't do this
for this reason but we get all the
spiritual benefits mentioned and also
numerous health benefits starting from
the evolution that we do before prayer
and all the way through the different
postures and movements and then the
grounding that we do when we put our
heads to the ground that won't check out
the video I did on the health benefits
of grounding and we do that minimum in
salat 5 times a day so again we get the
best of both worlds spiritual and
physical health benefits by what by
obeying our Creator thank you
brothers and sisters now go pray
[Music]
Oh